Transcriber: sultana idris
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
قبل البدء، أود أن أسئلكم عدة أسئلة
يمكنكم الإجابة عليها برفع أيديكم
من منكم يقرأ؟
جيد. جميل.
من منكم يقرأ في مجال تخصصه
كي يحسن من نفسه ويتطور في عمله؟
حسناً.
من منكم يقرأ بلغة غير اللغة العربية؟
من منكم تحمس لقراءة كتاب ما لأنه سمع عنه
من شخص؟ شخص ما قال له: “هذا كتابٌ جميل”
يبدو أن الكثير منكم كذلك.
حسناً.
من منكم سمع من شخص أن كتاباً ما سيء
وبناء على كلامه لم يقرأ الكتاب؟
الكثير منكم كذلك فعلاً!
حسناً.
هنالك أشياء تكررت، صحيح؟
قال، قال لك، يقول، وما شابههم.
هذا صحيح. إن ثقافتنا نفسها مبني أحياناً
على هذا الحكاية.
وهذه الحكاية تترجم أحياناً إلى الكتب.
هل شكل الحكاية أو شكل الكتب
أو محتوى الكتب، نفسه
منذ بدء التأليف في مصر حتى الآن؟
لا. اِختلف شكل الكتب مع اِختلاف الزمن
وكان هنالك محاولات لكتابة أول رواية
مصرية في القرن التاسع عشر
ثم توالت محاولات التأليف وظهرت أول رواية
بالشكل الذي نعرفه اليوم
وهي رواية زينب لمحمد حسين هيكل
وتتطورت بعدها روايات لكُتاب كبار نعرفهم
جميعاً مثل دكتور طه حسين
يوسف...، توفيق الحكيم،
يوسف السباعي، يوسف إدريس،
وكاتبنا الكبير نجيب محفوظ،
بالإضافة إلى العديد من كُتاب ذلك الزمن.
نحن أنفسنا بالإضافة إلى الكُتاب
نسمي ذلك الزمن “زمن الفن الجميل”
لماذا أطلقنا عليه هذا الاسم؟
ذلك الزمن يحتوي على إنتاج أدبي ضخم جداً
موجود إلى الآن ويعيش بيننا
وجميعنا نعود إليه
سواء نعود له لغرض الهواية أو لغيرها
إنها فروقات شخصية
أنا أحب نجيب محفوظ إذاً سأقرأ رواياته
أو لأغراض الترجمة.
شخص تم تكليفه بترجمة أعمال كاتب معين.
أو طلاب الأدب واللغة الذين يعودون لهذه
الروايات
كأمثلة تطبيقية
في الدراسات العلمية والأدبية.
حسناً، أثناء قراءتنا، أيً كان الغرض
من القراءة، نجد نفسنا مجبرين
على المقارنة بين مستوى هذا الرويات
ومحتواها
وبين الروايات الموجودة حالياً. صحيح؟
حسناً.
الغريب في الأمر أن هذه المقارنة
تكون دائماً في صالح الكُتاب الكبار.
صحيح؟ أجل.
لماذا يا ترى؟
هل هنالك أسباب؟
من المؤكد ذلك.
هذه الأسباب هي أربع نقاط كما نراهم هنا.
أول نقطة هي اللغة.
لغة هذه الأعمال لغة راقية، لغة رصينة
إذا أردنا اِستخدام المصطلح التقني.
وهذه اللغة تمزج ما بين اللهجة المصرية
واللغة العربية الفصحى
وأفضل كاتب تميز في هذا المجال
هو كاتبنا الكبير نجيب محفوظ.
النقطة الثانية التي تبرر أهمية هذه الأعمال
هي أنها تعكس المجتمع المصري في زمن الكاتب.
وأنتَ تقرأ لنجيب محفوظ تشعر فعلاً
أنك تشاهد فيديو عالي الجودة
لحي الجمالية أو مصر القديمة إلخ.
إضافة مهمة، هذه الرويات يمكننا تسميتها
عابرة للزمن
ما معنى عابرة للزمن؟
نحن الآن في 2021،
لكن لو قرأنا رواية لأحد الكتاب الكبار
سنجد أنفسنا فيها، لن نشعر بالغربة.
وربما بعد 30 أو 40 عام سنشعر بنفس الشعور،
لأن هذه الروايات نابعة من قلب مجتمعنا
مما أنعكس على الموضوعات التي نوقشت
في هذه الروايات.
جميع الموضوعات كانت نابعة من المجتمع
ومشاكله، ومن قضايا اِجتماعية وفلسفية هامة.
مثل رواية أنا حرة، التي ناقشة عمل المرأة
وحقها في أن تختار أن تعمل أو تتزوج
أو أيً كان.
لبنى عبدالعزيز أجادت الدور بشكل رائع
في الفلم.
المثال الثاني هو رواية الباب المفتوح
للكاتبة لطيفة الزياد
التي ناقشت فيها مفهوم السلطة الأبوية
وعدم قدرة البنت على أخذ قرار في حياتها
ووجوب تحركها في النطاق الذي يتناسب
مع العادات والتقاليد والمجتمع
أعني لم تكن شيء لكسر المجتمع فقط.
حسناً،
لماذا نشعر بوجود فرق؟
لماذا نشعر بوجود فجوة بين أعمال الكُتاب
الكبار
وبعض الأعمال التي نقرأها الآن؟
ما السبب برأيكم؟
هل نحن كقراء اِختلف ذوقنا؟
هل الكُتاب هم السبب؟
هل وسائل التواصل الاِجتماعي هي السبب؟
هل التكنولوجيا هي السبب؟
أما ماذا بالضبط؟
الحقيقة هي أن كل هذه الأشياء هي السبب.
مثلما كانت اللغة عامل مهم في أن الأعمال
القديمة تستمر لهذا اليوم
بعض الكُتاب الحاليين -بعضهم فقط للأمانة-
لغتهم ليست بقوية
لغتهم ركيكة جداً
والموضوعات التي تُناقش في هذه الأعمال
موضوعات سطحية للأسف.
لا ترقى لمفهوم الأدب الذي اِعتدنا عليه
بالإضافة إلى أن محتوى الكتاب لن يتذكره
أحدٌ منا بعد الإنتهاء من الكتاب
هذا إذا تمكنا بالفعل من إنهاء الكتاب
إضافة ثانية مهمة، وقد تكون الجانب
الإيجابي لبعض الأعمال الموجودة حالياً
أنها إبتدأت تواكب سرعة
وأسلوب حياتنا الجديدة
والموضوعات والقضايا التي تناقشها أيضاً
أصبحت جديدة
تأثير التكنولوجيا في الأعمال الحالية
واضح جداً
وتأثير التكنولوجيا في حياتنا أدى لظهور
أشياء جديدة لم تكن موجودة سابقاً
مثل التنمر وجرائم الإنترنت
وقد تم مناقشتها في بعض الأعمال.
حسناً، سؤال إضافي.
هل أثرت التكنولوجيا بالإيجاب
على بعض أشكال الأعمال الأدبية؟
أجل. أصبح لدينا كتب بصيغة الـpdf
للأشخاص الذين لا يحبون الكتب الورقية
وأصبح لدينا كتب صوتية،
وهي مفيدة جداً
للمحرومين من نعمة البصر
الكتب الصوتية بديل ممتاز لهم.
وأصبح لدينا أيضاً روايات رقمية وتفاعلية
حسناً، سؤال آخر مهم.
هل الأعمال الموجودة حالياً جميعها أعمال
جيدة؟ لا.
حسناً، هل الأعمال الغير جيدة كثيرة؟
في الحقيقة لا.
يا لها من مفاجأة صحيح؟
حسناً، ما السبب في شعورنا بأن الأعمال
الرديئة كثيرة ومنتشرة ولا يوجد سواها؟
وسائل التواصل الاِجتماعي.
ما يحدث هو أنه حين يصدر كتاب جديد
من الكتب التي لا نحبها ولا نصنفها كأدب
ولا نؤيد طبعها.
ما يحدث هو
أن القراء الذين يتوافق ذوقهم مع هذا النوع
من الكتب يكتبون عنها على مواقع التواصل
فتظهر هذه المؤلفات في الترند
وينتشر الهاشتاغ إلخ
هذا ما يحدث للأسف.
حسناً، هل الصورة غامقة لهذه الدرجة؟
هل المشكلة لدينا كبيرة لهذه الدرجة؟
في الحقيقة لا.
الكلام الذي سأقوله الآن كلام علمي
مبني على أرقام
بالنظر إلى تقريرين مهمين جداً
أحدهم اسمه مؤشر القراءة العربي
وأخر نسخة منه كانت عام 2016
من مؤسسة محمد بن راشد آل مكتوم
في دبي، دولة الإمارات.
وجدوا أن نسبة القراءة في مصر في المطلق
89%، وهو رقم ضخم
ويستحق الذكر أن في الوقت التي أجريت فيه
هذه الدراسة كان عددنا حوالي 92 مليون
وعدد المشاركين في هذه الدراسة ما يقارب
53 ألف مشترك
وهو رقم قليل.
ما ستجدونه غريب هو أن الأرقام التي سأقولها
الآن تساوي تقريباً نسبتها
لنسبة من رفعوا أيديهم في الأسئلة
التي سألتها في الأول
وهذا أكبر دليل على أنها أقرب للصحة.
الأهمية في هذه الدراسة تكمن في أنهم قاموا
بتقسيمها لعدة أجزاء
متوسط ساعات القراءة للأشخاص الذين يقرؤون
في تخصصهم
مقابل الأشخاص الذين يقرؤون في غير تخصصهم
وأيضاً منسوب القراءة وإتاحة الكتب نفسها.
هل الكتب موجودة؟
أم أننا نجد صعوبة في الحصول عليها.
الكتب في مصر متاحة بنسبة 83% تقريباً
وهي نسبة كبيرة.
حسناً.
إذا ألقينا نظرة مرة أخرى على الأرقام
المهمة، سنرى هنا
متوسط عدد الكتب المقروءة
بالمقارنة مع عدد متوسط ساعات القراءة
والرقم الموجود هنا كبير، على الرغم من أننا
نُوصف دائماً كشعب لا يقرأ، هو أمر خاطيء
عدد ساعات القراءة للأشخاص الذين يقرؤون
بلغة أجنبية هو 10 ساعات في الأسبوع
ويعد كثيراً.
أشخاص يقرأون في خارج تخصصات العمل.
وهو رقم كبير أيضاً.
وأشخاص يقرأون وسائط إلكترونية وهم أكثر
وهو ما يأكد لنا بأن التكنولوجيا قامت
بدور إيجابي من هذه الناحية.
حسناً، هل لدينا كُتاب جيدين هذه الأيام؟
نعم، موجودين. كثيرين؟ أجل.
كُتاب مثل دكتور خالد توفيق
دكتورة رضوى عاشور، دكتورة إيمان مرسال
وقد فازت بالبوكر من فترة قصيرة
المستشار أشرف العشماوي، عمر طاهر
ريم بسيوني
شرين هنائي، خيري شلبي رحمة الله عليه،
عزت القمحاوي وغيرهم كثيرين
لن يسعنى الوقت لأن نذكرهم جميعاً
لانهم كثيرين فعلاً
حسناً، أين المشكلة؟
لماذا لا نعرف هؤلاء الكُتاب وغيرهم جيداً؟
لماذا ليسوا متصدرين قوائم الأكثر مبيعاً
والأكثر قراءة إلخ؟
المشكلة في الترند. السوشال ميديا
يعمل الكتاب الجيدين في صمت أغلب الوقت
وينتجون.
وقرائهم مشغلون بمتابعة الجديد دائماً
لذا لا يكتبون عنهم على مواقع التواصل
الاِجتماعي للأسف الشديد.
وبالتالي، لكي تعرف يجب أن تكون قد سمعت
من شخص يعرف.
إذاً هل الدنيا مظلمة؟ لا ليس لهذه الدرجة.
هل في مرة فكرة الترند خدمتنا؟
سلطت الضوء فعلاً على كاتب جيد؟
حصل.
بعد وفاة دكتور خالد توفيق
جميع محبيه وقرائه أصابتهم صحوة
وملئم الإنترنت بصوره وأغلفة كتبه
ومقولات مشهورة له، أهمها هذه،
“أريد أن يكتب على قبري جعل الشباب يقرؤون”
وقد حدث ذلك. نتيجة الترند والضوء الذي سُلط
على عمل جيد
وسُلب من الأعمال الرديئة.
كُتبه تصدرت قائمة الأكثر مبيعاً
والأكثر قراءة مرة أخرى حتى يومنا هذا.
حسناً، المفاجأة الأكبر هي أن مصر
في الـ6 سنوات الأخيرة
أصبحت متصدرة المراكز الأولى في معظم
الجوائز العربية للأعمال الإبداعية
والغير إبداعية مثل كتابات التاريخ
والنقد الأدبي والعلوم الاِجتماعية إلخ.
هنالك أمثلة كثيرة لهذه الجوائز، بعضها
موجود في مصر مثل جائزة نجيب محفوظ للرواية
وجائزة نجيب ساويرس للرواية
وكلاهما من الجوائز السنوية.
وبعضهم في الوطن العربي، مثل جائزة الشارقة
وأبو ظبي للقراءة
وهنالك أيضاً جائزة كتارا وهي من أهم
الجوائز الموجودة
بخلاف جائزة البوكر العربية التي فاز بها
أكثر من روائي مصري على مدى السنين الأخيرة.
المفاجأة الأكبر هي أن حالياً السعودية
والإمارات تحديداً من بين دول الخليج
إبتدأت لديهم حركة السينما والمسرح.
من الذين يكتبون السيناريوهات؟
المصرين.
يطلبونهم  لكي يألفوا النصوص المسرحية
والسينمائية لأننا الأصل.
كُتابنا فعلاً أقوياء.
حسناً، إننا نعاني من مشكلة.
نحن لا نعرف من الجيد
ما الحل برأيكم؟
أن نكتب. بالكتابة.
أن نكتب عن كل كتاب جيد قرأناه. ليس من
الضروري أن يكون عمل إبداعي، رواية، مسرحية
قد يكون كتاب متخصص في مجال من مجالاتنا
ولاقى إستحساننا وشعرنا أنه مفيد
نكتب عنه على السوشال ميديا لأنها أكثر
وسيلة سريعة للإنتشار
حسناً، هل ذلك سينجح فعلاً؟
في الحقيقة لقد جربت ذلك ونجح فعلاً.
قبل عدة سنوات، طلبت من تلاميذي في الصيف
أن يكتبوا عن الكتب التي أعجبتهم وأثرت فيهم
سأذكر هنا مثالين، أحد الطلاب كتب عن
رواية قرأها وكانت مترجمة
لأن اللغة الأصلية للرواية هي الإسبانية
والطالب لا يتقن الإسبانية
كتب عن رواية مئة عام من العزلة
لغابرييل غارسيا ماركيز.
إندهش الفتى لأن عالم غابرييل غارسيا ماركيز
كان مختلف تماماً
لأن ماركيز لاتيني والفتى يعيش في مصر
بحث عن ماركيز وقرأ عن المدرسة الأدبية
التي ينتمي لها
غابرييل غارسيا ماركيز وهي الواقعية السحرية
أعجبه الأمر، فبدأ يقرأ أكثر من رواية
لماركيز
وقرر في النهاية أن يدرس ماركيز
في بحث التخرج الخاص به.
وهو ما يعتبر طفرة.
مثال ثاني، في بعض الأحيان أهدي طلابي كتب
وقد أهديت هذا الطالب كتاب صنايعة مصر
لعمر طاهر
قرأ الفتى الكتاب وسعد به جداً، لأن الكتاب
ينتمي لمدرسة الصحافة الإستقصائية.
وعمر طاهر بذل فيه مجهود رائع وأدرج فيه
كم هائل من المعلومات عن أسماء
أثرت في الوعي الثقافي
وفي بناء المجتمع في مصر
أعجب الفتى بالكتاب جداً، وبدأ يتحدث
عن المعلومات التي وجدها مفيدة
وقد بحث عن هذه المعلومات أكثر
وأعجب بأسلوب كتابة عمر طاهر،
ونشر منشور
آخر بعد قراءة أكثر من كتاب لعمر طاهر
عن طريقة عمر طاهر في الكتابة ومدى روعتها
وفتح النقاش
عن أساليب عمر طاهر المختلفة وما هي
أساليب الكتابة والمدارس الأدبية للكتابة
هنالك فرق أليس كذلك؟ نعم
هل ترون أن الأمر يستحق
أن نكتب عن الأمور الجميلة لنساعدها
على الاِنتشار
بدل أن تعيش في الظلام؟ نعم يستحق.
جربوا ولن تندموا.
شكراً